my name is Barry Allen and an innocent
man I'm being framed for something that
I didn't do
he stood among us or wolf sheep's
clothing this is the only way tell
everyone you're the flash if every one
of my secret we would never be able to
stop running your honor I miss I didn't
do this I didn't kill him
I was waiting
he's gonna be staying with us for
what you sees the speedforce your past
your present your future all at once so
you need to focus on where you want to
go so from his perspective all that
nonsense he's saying make sense it's too
bad we don't have a translator you know
what we can make one
if you've miscalculated by even a death
there is not a decimal a fraction an
infinitesimally RIA belong my thought
beyond my mind even now the seven
thousand seven hundred and ninety eight
variations of this argument
I have anticipated them all and know how
it ends then how does it end
the only way it can end with my victory
suddenly buries gibberish at the
beginning of the season makes a little
more sense that season one moment when
he was running back to save his mother
so there's a whole bunch of Easter eggs
in this Pro Mode so because we're
heading into the break be sure to
subscribe to get everything there'll be
bonus videos for all kinds of DC TV
stuff including Titans there'll be a
bunch of new stuff dropping in the next
couple of weeks so I'll still be doing
the flash ring giveaway I'll explain at
the end of the video but I might think
of a different giveaway to do for the
Titans videos you guys can leave all
your suggestions in the comments below
but you all probably know about the
trial of the flash even if you haven't
read it in a long time it's a really old
comic book arc and there's a big Easter
Egg for it in Barrie's booking number at
the CCPD jail when they're hauling his
ass in so the number reads 12 1984
that's actually an easter egg for the
first big issue of his trial in the
comics the trial of the flash now the
story arc the trial of the flash is
almost twenty four issues long but to
think about that is that also includes
all the issues leading up to the
reverse-flash developing a plan to take
out Fiona Webb to flash killing him
there's a bunch of issues where the
Rogues get involved and then there's the
resolution of that there aren't that
many issues of him actually sitting in a
courtroom like you see these funny
pictures of him sitting in his flash
costume with Kid Flash walking in to
testify that's only a small part of this
big story arc but it starts with the
flash number 323 run flash run for your
wife it ends around flash number 349 and
the truth shall set him free in this big
double issue number 350 flash flees but
a lot of you have been wondering what's
going on with the cecile character
obviously she's advising Barry during
this trial you should give up your
identity tell everyone you're the flash
that's the only way to beat this she was
also Flash's defense attorney through
that whole comic book arc so it makes a
little more sense why they're focusing
so much on cecile this season because
she was a big part of that comic book
storyline but I'm not expecting the
trial to last nearly as long as it did
in the comics maybe a couple episodes
before they resolve it but the cool
thing is is that at the end of that
storyline a fake professor zoom shows up
that's actually abracadabra in disguise
so maybe we'll see
come back in the back half of the season
we saw him during season 3 he was the
one that read off all those names and
said the Deveaux would be one of his
greatest villains see here it is in the
future you and I have been enemies for
years
jealous
I wonder what face I'll be wearing next
time we meet can't wait I'm not
expecting them to do everything from the
trial storyline and because it was all
about the reverse-flash that had
supposedly been killed and it's the
thinker on the TV show I'm just
expecting a couple more minor changes
but we can just follow along as they do
the trial storyline one of the other
funny twist of the comic book storyline
is they found out that abracadabra had
actually brainwashed the jury against
the flash so they acquitted him of the
charges and that's the technicality that
helps set him free but they really drug
out that storyline like they made you
wonder whether or not the flash would be
able to continue being the flash if he
was a fugitive and that's kind of what
they get across in this trailer Barry
has to go through the justice system
even though they'll probably be some
think or twist where he tries to
manipulate everyone now that he has the
ability to read people's minds but for
all the people that are asking why he
didn't clean up the crime scene and why
they're taking it in this direction just
remember that the thinker had plans for
every eventualities so no matter what
action that Barry took in that moment if
he decided to clean the body up the
thinker had probably planned for that
eventualities so the takeaway is is it
no matter what Barry would have been
thrown in prison I think people just
forget that scene that the thinker had
with his wife when they were arguing and
he basically had a billion different
versions of the argument in his head
within an instant and in all
eventualities he had beaten her so the
flash just hasn't gotten to the point
where he can out think the thinker so no
matter what he'd be in jail the other
big thing about this though obviously we
know that the flash is going to prove
his innocence with some big twist
somehow but the other big part of this
is Wally in legends of tomorrow because
there was a big cast reshuffle on that
TV show I'll talk about it when I do
constantine legends of tomorrow video
because constantine is get starring for
two episodes when they come back in
January but I do think that there's a
strong possibility while they could go
on legends of tomorrow because they're
not really using him that much on the
flash TV show and they want Barry to
struggle and when you have two versions
of the flash it's almost like there's no
problem that they can't solve so I think
the idea is is that if you bench Wally
everyone's gonna be pissed
so because well is one of the best
characters that they have and now it
seems like two characters have left
legends of tomorrow it just seems like
the no brainer option to put him on
legends of tomorrow they have too many
c-list characters they need to upgrade
just a little bit I feel like Wally
would be that upgrade but I'll talk
about that a little bit more when I do
my legends of tomorrow video later today
the other thing about the reverse-flash
because we're doing the trial of the
flash and there's a lot of reverse flash
Easter eggs in here is that the thinker
is swapping bodies it now sounds like
he's actually gonna stay in Dominic's
body for most of the rest of the season
I don't know how big the actor is but
that doesn't mean that Neal salyanz' the
person who was playing this version of
the thinker has completely left the show
that was probably the other biggest
question that I got they might bounce
back and forth between the different
versions depending on where the scene is
happening if he's walking around in
broad daylight then it'll be Dominic as
the thinker we might wind up seeing the
original version when he's back in his
sanctuary talking to his wife they
haven't fully explained the mechanics of
that I know everybody's wondering about
that teleport during episode 9 like wow
he just teleported into midair how did
that work words that technology come
from we'll find out a little bit more as
they drop more footage but just leave
all your bonus video requests in the
comments below
like I said legends of tomorrow we'll
post next I'll talk all about
Constantine then there'll be some new
Titans later this week but because we
have all this Star Wars Avenger stuff
fox marble deal I'll try to get through
everything as fast as possible so
there's a whole bunch of comic book
stuff dropping this week but there's a
new round of that blast ring giveaway
all you have to do to enter just be a
subscriber leave a comment on this video
congratulations to the winner from my
last video earth-1 Batman please private
message me so I can get your contact
details click here for my episode 9
video and click here to start getting
ready for Star Wars the last Jedi thank
you so much for watching everybody
they awesome I'll see you guys tonight